لن تهدا ولا افق لنهايتها هي حرب طويله
الامد لكن الى متى لا احد يدري سوى الرئيس
في الحرب الاوكرانيه يتصاعد خطر الحرب
النوويه المسؤولون الروس يؤكدونا ان قوه
الردع النووي في حاله تاهب تام لغه تحذير
وتهديد لم تهدا منذ اشهر
انه لن يستخدمه السلاح النووي ابقى الباب
مفتوحا على كل الخيارات الرد سيكون بالمثل
على اي هجوم نووي
موسكو اكدت ايضا التزامها بتعليق نشر
الصواريخ النوويه متوسطه المدى في اوروبا
ما دامت الولايات المتحده لم تنشر مثل تلك
الاسلحه في اوروبا او اسيا
دي ارجون بريكالوريا
ماشيمن وناسف الانتهاءها في اغسطس 2019
بسبب سياسات التدميريه للولايات المتحده
وانسحابها منها والان هناك فراغ في
اللوائح الدوليه بمجال الصواريخ النوويه
يمكن ان يكون له مخاطر اضافيه على الامن
العالمي ورغم الحديث المتصاعد عن الخطر
النووي الا ان الامين العام لحلف الناتو
يرى ان خطر استخدام روسيا للنووي في
اوكرانيا ضئيل لكنه مازال ياخذ الامور على
محمل الجده
موسكوت تتهموا واشنطن بالتوجه عمدا لتصعيد
الصراع في اوكرانيا كما تتهم الغرب
والنيتو باللعب بالنار خصوصا في توسعه
بتسليم اسلحه بعيده المدى والاثقل
لاوكرانيا من دون قيود
لكن بالتزامن مع هذا التوتر
يرى ان خطر اللجوء روسيا للنووي تراجع لان
المجتمع الدولي رسم خطا احمر لروسيا على
هذا الصعيد والاهم ان شغلت قرر دعوه مكرون
لمناقشه الضمانات الامنيه التي طلبها
بوتنه قبل اشهر واحد انهاء عمليته
والانسحاب من اوكرانيا